I mean you don't have to go far on the
interweb to find quite extreme reactions
to that scene with your shirt on here's
what somebody tell me Michael B Jordan
that my ovaries are ready to eat
Mike the seeds or there's more there's
more is another one this Michael B
Jordan make anyone else want to rip
their lungs out even erotic reaction so
creative so sexy I'm gonna eat my lung I
would sell Fritos and one kidney to be
in the same room is there a market for
toes every time I think about Michael B
Jordan my uterus combusts into play
[Applause]
and of course now I suppose there'll be
a whole new generation of kids who fall
in love with this Mary Poppins and so
Emily are your kids how are they with it
well I think um I mean my youngest my
two year old has a sort of attention
span of a fly so she watches the trailer
but hazel who's almost five has seen it
and just absolutely loved it and sort of
wants to talk about it all the time now
and yeah it was really weird
your mother's Mary Poppins I do think
she C I think she just thinks it's
normal she's like well that's what this
is what Sunny's mummy does and this is
what my mummy does you know it's just
sort of like quite conversational for
her
is it gonna help or hinder discipline at
home Oh hinder really yeah I think so
because she knows she already knows I
can't fly she's not what she was baby
but she did ask me to do the voice the
other day just out of nowhere
because she was quite sort of impassive
watching the film just sort of didn't
just sort of didn't reveal much of what
she felt and then the other day she goes
do your she's American of course sounds
American she good she good she goes do
your Mary Poppins voice and I go
spit-spot and off we go and she goes
[Applause]
where I say to the to the dolphin no no
not yet and now the two of them go no
not yet you are good at English accents
oh you are oh you have that you have a
decent English like an etiquette you
think Chris could do well one of our
most popular ones probably not very
politically correct so we'll do it
sounds
a tailor with a guy called Mark Williams
and we used to we were very over
familiar say hello sir
try that in Cillian hello sir hello sir
were you out with a lady last night sir
oh did you want it with a lady last
night well a married couple comes up and
they want to take a picture and then
jitan generally it's the woman that
wants to get the hug and then they want
me to push their husband away so I do it
but sometimes it's the man and you know
it's well we've got some examples here
you are but like he's like jigs acting
this this is just tragic this next one
because I feel like he just got a
girlfriend and he's properly upset do
you have another one and look at that Oh
beautiful
check that out
and this last one is is kind of doubly
cruel because obviously she's killed a
pet dog I'm just pushing him away when
you sign the photograph you side over
it's that you always kind of dread that
they're a bit you know even you wrote it
but other bit some tongue twister yeah
yeah well the first Hamilton's first big
song in the show is called my shot and
it is the biggest sort of meal in terms
of lyrics and if you can get through
that you've got the show you can it's
the sort of sort of like the way
Hamlet's like six major monologues it's
like if you can get my shot you've got
it can I poke it with a stick and you do
it as a tiny bit scholarship to Kings
College
I probably shouldn't brag but Eragon
amazing astonished the problem is I got
a lot of brains but no polish I got a
hollow just to be heard with every word
I dropped knowledge I'm a diamond in the
rough I shine a piece of coal trying to
reach my goal my power of speech
unimpeachable only 19 but my mind is
older these New York City streets get
cold a shoulder every burden every
disadvantage I've learned to manage I
don't have a gun to brandish I walk
these streets famished the plan is to
fan this spark into a flame but damn is
getting dark so let me spell out the
name I am there yeah DX again D er we
are meant to be a colony that runs
independently meanwhile Britain keeps
[ __ ] on us endlessly they tax us
relentlessly thinking jaws shows around
and Reza's spending spree penny ain't
never gonna say his descendants free so
there will be a revolution in the
century and to me he says in parentheses
don't be shocked when your history book
mentions me I will lay down my life if
it sets us free eventually you'll see my
ascendancy and I am NOT throwing away my
shot at something like that
talking of sleepwalking Jamie Dornan
hello now you don't sleep eat sleep eat
you don't sleep eat obably not no no but
you do sleepwalk listen I I that I'm
aware of
I've slept once in my life I was about
11 or 12 I've told some shockers on this
show before I woke up and my dad was at
the end of my bed and he said morning TV
morning you said your manling to tell me
said not really slept well you said um
do you think you slept last night not
usually do that sort of thing is them
what someone's done a poo in the bath
as it turns out by sort of the process
of an elimination my sister's to working
his way going to the hole
but you decided you were garden to learn
how to fly because you know I'm strong
enough playing this right yeah how did
that go you know Neil could fly before
he could drive he he grew up washing
planes as a kid so he could pay for
lessons and flight was just you know I'm
so important to him so I thought oh I'll
learn how to fly and you know you always
hear about celebrities flying and I was
like how hard could it be
well it's very hard it's very hard and
pretty quickly into my training my
flight instructor told me to take the
plane into a self-imposed all it's just
you you stall it on purpose and I just
thought this is a terrible idea
I'm gonna land right away and I'll spend
my time learning other things as luck
would have it Patrick Stewart has also
done drag how beautiful
that is actually close up is a little
beautiful
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but now you have a drag named of you oh
yeah
patty lost you
[Music]
you